does this really show that wind power is
getting more efficient or doesn't it
just show that it's had lots of
subsidies flung at it and this has just
made it more scalable no we are
undoubtedly becoming much more efficient
I guess the pattern is one that is quite
predictable if you think about it we're
still a fairly young industry and what
we're seeing is we're in the steep part
of the learning curve where economies of
scale and scope the benefits of
experience are really starting to take
hold and we're seeing costs tumble as
you just described but I'm in a subsidy
is still a subsidy I mean it is still
worth pointing out that even though 5750
this is substantially higher than the
current spot price which is about 43
pounds and megawatt-hour what it is but
it's considerably less than it was and
and it's got us into a position where
you can think of in terms of subsidy
parity if you like with other forms of
generation we really are now in the mix
with conventional forms of generation
technology fossil technologies and
that's before you factor in of course
the the benefit of zero carbon footprint
so it makes a really compelling
proposition but is it really meaningful
to compare one form of energy with
another one for example wind power is
intermittent the wind doesn't always
blow I mean same as so that the Sun
doesn't always shine with things like
nuclear it's always there it's always on
yeah and there is undoubtedly a benefit
of that and nuclear proponents will say
you know it's baseload as you say it's
always there I'm certainly not going to
argue that there's no value to that but
what I find really interesting and
really exciting is progress in energy
storage technologies the ability to sort
of harness renewable technologies like
offshore wind store it in batteries
convert it to hydrogen all of these
forms of energy are tumbling in price
and it opens up the prospect of an
entirely green energy system for the
future a new energy paradigm no you're
not suggesting that I'm because wind
power is intermittent we still need that
backup base load I mean would you for
example still go ahead with Hinkley
Point C well fortunately I don't have to
make that decision I I think what's
really good is that question is starting
to be asked on it and it now becomes
ripe we have a renewable technology that
we can deploy at massive scale and the
North Sea has almost limitless potential
here we could power Europe 1.8 times
over just
from the energy in the North Sea so it
becomes a very right question I think we
therefore need to debate the benefits of
intermittency versus baseload and look
to see how we can bring on those
renewable storage technologies to
complement wind very briefly when will
this storage technology really start to
bring about meaningful cost cuts well I
think I think we're seeing it and we're
seeing batteries deployed in in domestic
premises across Europe particularly
Germany we're seeing electric vehicles
becoming much more cost effective so
we're seeing the battery costs tumbling
as much as offshore wind Matthew Wright
appreciate you joining thanks my
pleasure thank you thanks